[Musik]
Ukraine unter Zeitdruck kleine Erfolge
große Ungeduld Fragezeichen guten Abend
es ist Donnerstagabend gut dass sie
wieder mit dabei sind putin ist jede
Hilfe Recht auch die von Nordkorea ist
Diktator Kim Jong-un eine neue Achse des
Bösen oder ein letzter Strohhalm die
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine kommt dagegen
voran aber kann es der ukrainischen
Armee noch gelingen das ganze Land von
den Invasoren zu befreien einschließlich
der Krim nicht nur Zeit ist knapp wir
müssen reden mit diesen Gästen
der Parteivorsitzende der Grünen omidor
die stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin der Ukraine
Hanna
Norbert Röttgen CDU Außenpolitiker
der Militärexperte Gustav
die langjährige Russland Korrespondentin
Sabine Adler
und aus Washington ZDF-Studio Leiter
Elmar twissen
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt alle Gäste dieser Sendung
noch mal ausgesprochen herzlichen los
geht's Vladimir Putin findet immer noch
Freunde
es fühlt sich an wie ein Gipfeltreffen
auf dem Todesstern Darth Vader im
Doppelpack aber es sind lediglich zwei
Staatschefs die hallo sagen und viel zu
besprechen haben
[Musik]
der geliebte Führer kim will russische
Raketentechnologie
Präsident Putin braucht Munition aus dem
hochgerüsteten Nordkorea denn die
Ukraine hat tatsächlich die Hutz bei
sich zu verteidigen gegen Putins
Angriffskrieg
wie sollen wir denn die Militäraktion
stoppen wenn die andere Seite eine gegen
Offensive führt was sollen wir tun sie
werden uns angreifen und wir sagen wir
stoppen
Putin braucht Freunde kurz vor dem
Treffen mit Kim greift die Ukraine mit
Marschflugkörpern erfolgreich das
Hauptquartier der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte auf der Krim an
[Musik]
ist bei uns Militärexperte Herr gressel
das war tatsächlich eine Überraschung
wahrscheinlich auch für Putin und Kim
die Ukraine hat erfolgreich im Hafen von
Sebastopol zwei Kriegsschiffe der Russen
bombardiert ist das ein
Q der Ukraine oder ist es mehr ist sehr
gut vorbereitet der Aktion also wir
haben in den Wochen davor gesehen dass
Flieger Abwehrmittel der Russen gezielt
angegriffen werden zum Teil mit
infilterten Spezialkräften zum Teil mit
marschallkörpern
die Ukraine hat zwei Ölplattformen die
von den Russen für Radar und Geräte und
für elektronische kampfführungsmittel
genutzt werden vorher
eingenommen und diese Geräte abgebaut
und damit den Russen die vorwandzeit
genommen denn die stehen quasi auf der
Einflugschneise für diese Mario Körper
die jetzt in Polen zugeschlagen haben
und in Sebastian selber nicht nur die
zwei Kriegsschiffe sondern diese Praxis
Block können jetzt ein trockentalk das
für das einzige trockentalk auf der Krim
das militärisch für die
Schwarzmeerflotte das jetzt die
Reparaturmöglichkeiten für russische
Kriegsschiffe behindert das wiederum
senkt die Einsatzbereitschaft von
Schiffen der Schwarzmeerflotte und ihre
Möglichkeiten Sebastopol dauerhaft das
Hafen zu nutzen und vielleicht ihre
Möglichkeit
auch eine Basis die ist nur weiter
östlich russland will ja
getreidefrachter zum Beispiel hindern
ukrainische Häfen an zu laufen für all
das muss ich ja Richtung Odessa also
gegen Westen desto weiter östliches bin
desto längere Anfahrt Wege haben desto
mehr Schiffe brauche ich um die selbe
Präsenz aufrecht zu erhalten das heißt
hier mache ich den ganzen russischen
Operationen natürlich schwieriger
effektiv zu sein und das ist in ihren
Augen ein gut vorbereitet äh Kuh gewesen
der auch sehr präzise war weil einen
solchen Hafen ein solches doch zu
treffen lässt darauf schließen dass
präzise Marschflugkörper Christmas
wahrscheinlich britisches Storm Shadow
von dem was man weiß das sind sehr
präzise Geräte wir haben auch in der
Vergangenheit schon
öfters gute Schläge auch durchgeführt
mit diesen Waffen die funktionieren gut
genau Briten uns die Franzosen haben
genau diese Raketen zur Verfügung
gestellt Sabine Adler ist bei uns wir
Schätze russland-expertin vom
Deutschlandfunk vor aller jetzt gab es
interessanterweise auch sehr laut und
sehr deutlich Kritik in den britischen
und in den amerikanischen Medien genau
an diese Kriegsführung der Ukraine haben
sie verstanden warum die kamen und warum
die so öffentlich war oder was war Ihre
Interpretation ich habe mich gewundert
dass sie kam auch eben dass sie so
öffentlich kam denn es wurde ja auch
immer wieder klar bei einer 1000 km
lange Front und einer hoch
militarisierten Krim
da ist sie was Topol der ganz lange
Stützpunkt über viele viele Jahre und
Jahrhunderte ja eigentlich schon aber
die Krim ist ja seit 2014 sozusagen ein
einziger großer Militärstützpunkt wenn
man sich das anschaut wie diese Insel
aussieht oder Halbinsel aussieht dann
gab es da unten immer einen Punkt das
war der Militärstützpunkt und jetzt ist
die Karte die kann man zum Beispiel
sehen bei
Radio Liberty von der Krim also einem
Regionalprogramm oben auf dieser
Webseite kann man ganz genau sehen wie
viele Militärstützpunkte man kann sie
fast nicht mehr zählen also die will
sagen die Krim ist ein einziger
Militärstützpunkt von Russland genauso
ausgebaut in den letzten Jahren und dass
diese Aufgabe unmenschlich groß ist
diese riesige Übermacht die russische
die da eingefallen ist zurückzudringen
das ist klar die Ausstattung ist so wie
sie ist nämlich unzureichend die
Kampfkraft der Ukraine ist deutlich
unterlegen selbst wenn man jetzt nur
Bevölkerungszahlen gegenüberstellt dann
ist es eins zu vier in etwa also mir ist
nicht so ganz klar warum diese Kritik
kam produktiv konstruktive Asien
verzichten was würden Sie sagen Herr
gressel nur auch aus ihrem Verständnis
noch mal welche vermeintlichen Fehler
sollte da die Ukraine die ukrainische
Seite gemacht haben also die Kritik
richtete sich dran dass zu viele Achsen
des angriffsbetrieben wurden die
richtete sich daran dass die Ukraine
nicht massiv angreift und sie richtet
sich daran dass
sie zu schonend mit den eigenen Soldaten
umgehen das ist so Risiko wäre es ist
und halt diese drei Punkte kann ich
eigentlich militärischen nicht
nachvollziehen die Ukraine hat die
Pflicht ihre ihre Verbände zu halten sie
kann aus keinem tiefen Potenzial
schöpfen an Menschen dass sie die Leute
verheizen kann wie das Russland tut das
geht nicht sie muss auch mit den Leuten
ich trainiere dir ich bilde die los das
dauert lange Zeit und das Human Kapital
von gut ausgebildeten Soldaten ist enorm
hoch die kann ich nicht verschwenden das
zweite ist Minenfelder sehr dichte
Minenfelder geben mir wenig Chancen
starke Kräfte gleichzeitig an die Front
zu bringen die würden bei kanalisierten
Bewegungslinien nur Ziele für die
Artillerie darstellen also auch diese
Kritik gibt nicht es gibt meiner Ansicht
nach durchaus Dinge die man an der
Ukraine in der Vorbereitung dieser
Offensive kritisieren kann etwa die
Ausbildung der neu aufgestellten
Brigaden die nicht so optimal war im
Vergleich jetzt zum Beispiel zu alt
gedienten Brigade etc aber die kamen in
dieser Kritik nicht vor was meiner
Ansicht nach
durch gewisse Leute politisch motiviert
waren die eine depriotisierung der der
Hilfe für die Ukraine wollen und
sozusagen das politisch pushen das
sozusagen da gibt's ja diese think
Tanker die dann schreiben das ist ein
ungewinnbarer Kriege etc das ist ein
politischer Anschauung die dann durch
solche Kritik und solche liegt ja auch
ohne Namen anonym vorgetragen wird hier
versucht wird zu machen aber wir wollen
das genauer verstehen und sind auch
dankbar dass heute unter anderem aus
Kiel die stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin der Ukraine
zugeschaltet ist und schauen vielleicht
vorher gemeinsam noch mal was das für
Vorwürfe waren die da aus dem Westen kam
gerade mal 30 bis 45 Tage kampfwetter
bleiben für die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive das sagt us-staatschef
Marc Millie und fügt hinzu es gibt
Schlachten die noch nicht geschlagen
sind
sie haben den Teil den man erkämpfen
muss noch nicht hinter sich um zu
erreichen was Sie sich vorgenommen haben
[Musik]
nein Washington ist nicht zufrieden
Hauptkritik ukrainische Truppen werden
falsch eingesetzt die Ukraine bindet zu
viele Kräfte in bachmut und im Osten
anstatt die Front in Richtung melittopol
zu fossieren
auch auf die Gefahr hin das Kiew mehr
Soldaten und Kriegsgerät in den
russischen Minenfeldern verliert denn
der gamechanger heißt Krim nicht die
Rückeroberung sondern das Kappen der
russischen Versorgungslinien
auch Kiew weist das und selenski deutet
es offen an
wenn wir an den Verwaltungsgrenzen der
Krim sind denke ich kann man politisch
die Demilitarisierung Russlands auf dem
Gebiet der Krim vorantreiben
[Musik]
darin zumindest sind sich Kiew und
Washington einig die Ungeduld des
Westens und die Kritik an der
ukrainischen Kriegsführung aber sorgen
für Empörung
kritisizing the slow pays Kritik am
langsamen Tempo der Gegenoffensive
bedeutet ukrainischen Soldaten ins
Gesicht zu spucken
ich empfehle allen Kritikern die Klappe
zu halten in die Ukraine zu kommen und
selber einen Quadratzentimeter zu
befreien
Panama
ist stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin der Ukraine
Formular einen guten Abend zu ihnen
würden sie es genauso formulieren wie
ihr Kollege Kollege
befindet sich in einer äußerst
schwierigen Situation denn wir haben
weniger Kämpfer das haben wir schon
angedeutet und wir haben viel weniger
Waffen wir kämpfen unter den Bedingungen
dass der Feind dass wir den Feind
überlegen sind auch im in der Luft und
nach allen Kanonen der
Kriegswissenschaft kann man eine
offensive starten wenn man mehr Kämpfer
hat und mehr Waffen wir haben jedoch das
Risiko in Kauf genommen und mit weniger
Waffen und weniger Mann die gegen
unzensive gestartet und nicht desto
trotz gelingt es uns unsere
Ländereien und unsere Territorien
zurückzuerobern wir sind einzigartig wir
schützen unser
Soldaten und gegen alle Wissenschaft wir
starten unsere Offensive überall und
trotzdem haben wir weniger Verluste als
der Fans das erste was wir
berücksichtigen dass es das Leben
unserer Menschen das humane Kapital was
die verletzte die
kampfrichtung betrifft in Richtung
bachmut muss ich sagen er hat sich die
Anzahl der Technik nicht verändert und
die Anzahl der Truppen nicht verändert
gleichzeitig haben wir auch im Süden die
Offensive gestartet das heißt wir haben
die Kräfte nicht anders verteilt sondern
der
Offensive der Russen ist im Osten in
vier Richtungen gibt es eine große
umflächige
Kampfhandlungen seit 2014 im Prinzip und
Richtung bachmut das ist nur eine
Richtung und vier andere Richtung das
sind die stoßricht bin der Russen die
Situation kann ja nicht anders sein als
das was wir jetzt haben also es heißt
die
kampfrichtung ist in dieser in diesem
Gebiet das heißt es gibt gute Gründe
genau so zu verfahren wie die
ukrainische Armee das tut bei uns ist um
mit nuripur einer der zwei Vorsitzenden
der Grünen im Verteidigungsausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages
in diese Art und Weise Hinweise zu
bekommen von Verbündeten und Freunden
erstens ja es ist ein bisschen wohlfühl
am Schreibtisch zu sitzen mehrere
tausend Kilometer entfernt und unter
dich immer nur zu erzählen warum man es
besser weiß aber zweitens als einer der
sehr oft in der Ukraine war habe ich
gelernt dass man immer wieder auch
vertrauen können muss was die Ukraine
über ihr eigenes Land wissen und sagen
und gerade bachmut ist das beste
Beispiel was es an auf Reibung gegeben
hat der technischen Streitkräfte hat ja
zum Beispiel dazu geführt dass prigoshin
diesen Aufstand erprobt hat hat er dazu
geführt dass die Wagner Truppen heute
jetzt nicht mehr in der Ukraine sind in
der verfasst hat wie wir sie es vorher
kannten ich fühle mich nicht im Stande
zu sagen die Ukraine machen den bachmut
alles falsch das sieht gleichzeitig
alles dafür tun um ihre Leute nicht zu
verlieren im Gegensatz zur russischen
Seite die wirklich Leute einfach nur
noch ins Feuer schicken spricht doch für
Sie bei uns ist Norbert Röttgen CDU aus
dem Politiker Herr Röttgen wir wissen
und haben hier schon viel diskutiert
dass die Regierung in Washington und in
Berlin sehr vorsichtig agiert haben in
diesem Krieg ähm aber wenigstens gibt
Berlin öffentlich keine Hinweise gut
gemeinten schlecht gemeinten Ratschläge
würden Sie sagen na gut das wäre noch
schöner
wenn man vorsichtig findet
es ist Hilfe Verweigerung die möglich
ist für die ich keinen Grund sehe und es
gibt doch keinen Grund dafür und das
macht uns die USA bei alle Unterstützung
diese leistet
einzige Macht mit der auch langen
Verzögerung der Panzerlieferungen hat da
hatte sie noch sachliche Gründe dafür
hat sie gemacht mit der langen
Verzögerung der F16 und macht sie immer
noch mit der Nichtlieferung der
langstreckenmarschflugkörper und das
sind eigentlich Instrumente das wird der
Grenze bestätigen Waffensysteme die
braucht man für eine offensive man jagt
also die Ukrainer notgedrungen in diese
Offensive hinein diese machen müssen
ohne diese beiden Komponenten zu haben
und dann kritisiert man den
ausbleibenden Erfolg den und die Kritik
wird von den gräßel auf militärisch
nicht geteilt das maße ich mir nicht an
zu beurteilen aber selbst wenn man sie
teilt das dann öffentlich zu
kommentieren ist wirklich ungehörig und
man muss leider das ist eigentlich noch
schlimmer eine politische Motivation
dahinter vermuten denn die wissen ja was
sie damit bewirken wenn Sie eine
laufende Offensive durch den stärksten
Verbündeten militärisch fachlich
kritisieren dann hat es Effekte
psychologischer politischer Art die
waren intendiert
darum drückt es aus auch einen das
wissen wir ja auch einen Machtkampf ist
so viel gesagt einen richtungskampf in
der amerikanischen Administration der
Außenminister blinken ist auf der
anderen Seite und der
Sicherheitsberaterin ist der Anführer
das anderen Lagers das war ja im Sommer
das ist vorbei darum würde ich mal sagen
ist die gute Botschaft wieder am Ende
dass ich Sullivan und mit dieser Kritik
und der politischen Intention nicht
durchgesetzt also der us-staatschef ja
nun auch im September wieder meldete und
sagte die Ukraine hätte jetzt noch 30
bis 45 Tage was gäbe es eine bessere
Überleitung um jetzt unbedingt nach
Washington zu schalten zu unserem Studio
Leiter dort el MRT sind der übrigens
auch noch jüngsten mit dem Hans-jürgen
friedrichspreis ausgezeichnet wurde
herzlichen Glückwunsch und hier die
harte Frage ist das ein schwarzer Peter
Spiel immer die wissen dass die
US-Administration da betreibt um schon
mal vorzubeugen wenn am Ende
diese Situation in der Ukraine schlecht
aus geht
ja ich glaube es ist die Erkenntnis dass
es natürlich schwerer ist als man sich
vielleicht erhofft hatte aber vielleicht
auch das ist die Erkenntnis hier war es
einfach naiv zu glauben dass man eine
Offensive gegen feste
Verteidigungslinien erfolgreich
durchführen kann ohne die rückräume
wirklich auch mit in den Blick zu nehmen
und dafür braucht man eben lang reichen
eine Raketen wie die Amerikaner sie
haben aber sie haben sie eben nur in
begrenzter Zahl insgesamt 4000 attackens
so nennen sie sich die eine Reichweite
von bis zu 300 km haben und die werden
gebraucht andersrum auf der Welt z.B um
Südkorea zu schützen und deswegen ist
man so zurückhaltend im Militär general
Milli hat interessanterweise ja keine
offene Kritik geäußert sondern er hat
nur gesagt der Kampf ist so intensiv wie
er es noch nie bei irgendeinem Krieg
erlebt hat da schwingt ein Stück weit
auch Anerkennung gegenüber der Ukraine
mit aber er macht eben auch sehr klar
man muss möglichst bald voran kommen und
ich glaube das stimmt was Norbert
Röntgen sagte hinter den Kulissen werden
die stärker die wollen das eben diese
weitreichenden Raketen jetzt geliefert
werden und dieses wer hat Schuld wenn es
nicht so gut läuft spielt das eher eine
Rolle oder aber das mit jedem Monat die
Sorge auch in den USA größer wird das
ein nächster ein neuer Präsident Trump
aber auf jeden Fall nicht mehr bei
beiden heißt spielt das eine Rolle
schon viel kurzfristiger wir haben jetzt
Ende diesen Monat zwar wahrscheinlich
den Streit über den neuen Haushalt für
das nächste Jahr und da hat Joe Biden
noch einmal über 20 Milliarden Dollar
beantragt an Militärhilfen für die
Ukraine und es könnte eben dazu kommen
dass er das nicht durch den Kongress
bekommt das heißt es ist auch hier die
Erkenntnis dass die Zeit heilt man muss
im Grunde genommen möglichst schnell
Gewinne erzielen um auch hier im Land
rechtfertigen zu können dass man noch
mal nachlegt dass man das vorantreibt
und eben auch diese weitreichenden
Raketen liefert und natürlich schwingt
immer die Sorge mit das nächstes Jahr im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf am Ende sich
doch Donald Trump durchsetzen könnte
dann wäre zu erwarten dass am Ende Putin
diesen Krieg gewinnt in dem Trump einen
Deal mit ihm macht wenn es soweit käme
und ich glaube diese Erkenntnis hier
macht auch ein Stück weit Druck auf die
Ukraine dass sie z.B jetzt eben in den
Blick vor allen Dingen nimmt die Krim
weil hier wird in Washington das so
gesehen dass die Krim vom Nachschub
abzuschneiden dafür zu sorgen dass das
Kronjuwel im Grunde genommen für
Wladimir Putin in Gefahr gerät könnte
dafür sorgen dass er am Ende vielleicht
doch bereit ist von seinen
Maximalforderungen abzurücken dann ist
dennoch die Frage nicht beantwortet
warum man die Herr Röttgen und auch
Sabine Adler gestellt haben warum man
dann so öffentlich einen Partner kritis
und einen Freund kritisiert der unter
denkbar schlechtesten Bedingungen ist
und auch eine zeitlichen Druck macht
also dieses wir haben noch 30 bis 45
Tage kampfwetter das tut man ja auch
nicht ohne Not öffentlich bei der BBC
ich glaube wenn man das noch mal liest
der General Milli hat einfach die Fakten
sehr klar gemacht und natürlich ist der
Druck da und deswegen rechnen wir
eigentlich damit dass in den nächsten
Wochen über diese Fragen der
weitreichenden Raketen entschieden wird
nicht nur die amerikanischen attackens
sondern ganz wesentlich sind dann
natürlich auch die Taurus Raketen aus
Deutschland die noch eine viel größere
Reichweite haben 450 km und damit kann
man den Rückraum so abschneiden um
vielleicht auch an der Front schneller
voranzukommen wir fragen noch mal in
Kiel bei Hanna sie haben das jetzt
gehört auch diese washingtona Positionen
noch mal gehört was glauben sie wird es
gelingen diese Offensive in Richtung
Krim um abzuschneiden um diesen Landweg
abzuschneiden für die Versorgung wird
das gelingen
und das Verstehen ist deshalb was dessen
was eine Gegenoffensive ist haben die
meisten aus den Film
City hat die meisten Menschen die denken
na ja die Männer die setzen sich in die
Panzer und fahren irgendwohin ganz
schnell so ist es ja nicht damit die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte vorankommen
und unsere besetzten Gebiete
zurückerobern muss man einige
Frontlinien durchbrechen die die Russen
aufstellen wenn Sie die Gebiete besetzen
sie verstehen ganz gut dass wir diese
Gebiete wieder befreien wollen man muss
verstehen eine gegen Offensive ist es
nicht so man setzt sich in den Panzer
und fährt nach vorne das heißt man muss
ja verteidigungsprozess Potenzial der
russischen Streitkräfte vernichten und
diese Linien und abonnieren das heißt ja
mehrere Linien die sie aufgesetzt haben
es gibt ja Vermietung auf drei Ebenen
und das ist ja keine Handarbeit die
Vermietung zu die Entminung nein das ist
ja erst der erste Schritt man hat ja
drei verschiedene Schritte die man
durchlaufen muss und die Geschwindigkeit
ist damit verbunden dass man viele
Aufgaben hat und dann mit man schnell
vorankommt muss man den fein vernichten
und wenn es um die Geschwindigkeit geht
dann gibt es keine Kriterien es gibt ja
kein Maß an dem man das messen kann und
sagen man muss ja so machen und du
machst es so machst anders wir tun alles
was wir tun können in den Gegebenheiten
die wir haben die haben weniger Mann und
weniger Waffen und die Luftherrschaft
liegt bei den Russen
10 20 und mehrere Raketen fallen
tagtäglich bei uns auf dem Boden unsere
Zivilisten unsere Frauen und Kinder die
können nicht in Sicherheit leben und in
dieser Situation kämpfen wir wir geben
nicht nach damit sie einfach verstehen
unter welchen Bedingungen unsere
Soldaten leben sie lieben
unter der Erde was oben drauf ist wird
steht unter Beschuss wir haben nur zwei
Gebiete und jetzt kommt Lukas äh können
sie nur mal die Zahl in einer Woche
haben die Russen mehr als
380.000 das war letzte Woche
380.000
Einheiten Munition da kann man einfach
nicht oben sein da ist man nur im
schutzgraben und ganz ruhig stehen
unsere Soldaten und wenn man so sagt
dann versteht man einfach nicht Station
in welchem in welcher unser Land sich
befindet da ist noch mal sehr deutlich
geworden Herr gressel bei den
Schilderungen von Formular das im Grunde
eine Bodenoffensive ohne eine
Luftunterstützung geschehen muss da
sagen auch schlaue generelle dass es
eine Zumutung ist und wahrscheinlich
erstmals in der strategischen Planung
einer solchen Krieges überhaupt
auftaucht wie sehr rechnen Sie also wie
groß sozusagen ist tatsächlich die
Möglichkeit im Süden jetzt diesen Erfolg
zu generieren wenn es an anderen Stellen
der Front weiter den Versuch gibt
durchzubrechen denn das ist ja
offensichtlich das was der Westen
schaffen will er hatte die Vorstellung
dass es schnell gelingt da unten einen
Durchbruch hinzubekommen und das
zerschlägt sich nun es dauert länger wie
groß ist die Hoffnung dass man da
überhaupt erfolgreich ist also
wir sehen auch bei dieser Offensive dass
desto tiefer die ukrainischen Kräfte in
diese sehr dichten und sehr tiefen
russischen dispositive kommen desto
schneller geht die Offensive weil
tatsächlich stimmt das nur der erste
Brett hat
ausgestattet ist und die nächsten
verteidigungsringe nicht mehr so also
das eine ist
wir konzentrieren uns wenn wir diese
Linien anschauen immer auf die Bauwerke
weil man die vom Satellit zieht da gibt
es gute Blogger die mitschneiden wo die
sind das Problem ist dass sie nur die
Bauwerke aber eine technische Sperre ein
Panzergraben panzerigel Drachenzähne
sind nur so viel wert wie die Truppen
die sie verteidigen und mit Feuer
beobachten in der ersten Linie die
vorbereiten erstens dort sind die
Minenfelder enorm dicht
desto weiter man nach hinten kommt desto
weiter werden sie weil sich die
russischen Kräfte für ihre Gegend
offensiven ja auch schmeißen freihalten
durch diese angreifen können aber diese
Schneisen kann jetzt kann jetzt die
ukrainische Armee nutzen weil sie schon
tiefer steht das zweite ist diese Kräfte
die waren am Anfang dagegen Offensive
die Verteidiger die russische noch
frisch und sie haben die sechs acht
Monate die sie dort Ruhe gehabt haben
genutzt um sich nicht nur einzugraben
sondern um auch genau vor zu üben wie
sie die Verteidigung organisieren müssen
sie haben unterirdische Telefonkabel
verlegt sie haben Kommando Bunker sie
haben die Kommando Bunker dupliziert das
waren eine ausgeschaltet wenn Sie den
nächsten haben wirklich vorbereitet
solange man in dieser Linie einbricht
von vorne rennt dieses Uhrwerk an wie es
geplant ist aber desto tiefer man
drinsteht desto unten desto
ungewöhnlicher wird die
Gefechtssituation für diese
verteidigenden Truppen desto mehr müssen
sie improvisieren und hier ist und hier
ist die russische Armee schlechter weil
sie sehr hierarchisch sind weil sie sehr
von oben herab
Befehlen und dem Moment wo man in der
Tiefe steht wo die Gefechtssituation
nicht mehr die geplante ist sondern eine
neue eine andere sieht man
dass es Probleme gibt wie Ihr sehen in
diesem in diesem wichtigen Durchbruch
jetzt die 76 76 und die siebte luftlande
Division der russischen Armee als
Reserve hinein geworfen das sind die
Kronjuwelen dieser Armee und trotzdem
geht es für die Ukraine ukrainischen
Spitzen voran das das zeigt schon viel
wie lange auch schon diese
Verteidigungslinien erodiert werden
durch zerschießen von Artillerie doch
zerschießen von Stellungen und die
russische Seite wirklich schlecht und
die russische Seite wirklich schlecht
das ist natürlich die Glaskugel wie viel
Reserven hat die Ukraine noch um das
auszunutzen wenn das mal zusammenbricht
und wie viel Reserven hat Russland noch
einen Zusammenbruch aufzufangen
da muss ich ehrlich sagen wir haben nur
Schätzungen wir haben keine konkreten
Zahlen über beide und deshalb würde ich
mich sehr zurückhalten hier zu sagen die
Ukraine hat eine 40 oder eine 60
prozentige Chance oder dass das geht bis
wir sind Silvester oder nicht das ist
alles kaffeesudel lesen wir sind wieder
bei der Politik Henry pur die
Verbündeten sind offensichtlich davon
ausgegangen dass man am Ende des Jahres
diese
abgeschnittene Situation mit der Krim
erreicht hat die
und dass die gelieferten Waffen dafür
auch ausreichen würden glauben Sie dass
es möglich ist jetzt wirklich noch mal
nachzulegen auch ordentlich noch mal
nachzulegen über die Taurus reden wir
gleich selbstverständlich und das müssen
wir auch denn man sieht ja die Ukraine
kommt voran und man sieht das ist nicht
die Geschwindigkeit die man vom
Schreibtisch aus sich ausgedacht hat und
jetzt kommen in der Phase des Krieges wo
es wirklich ein Geduld spielt wird und
das sieht man ja eine Reaktionen
Washington dass da Leute auch
tatsächlich die Nerven verlieren und
genau darauf setzt ihr der Kreml und
deshalb gilt es dass wir natürlich nicht
nachlassen ein Beispiel natürlich
braucht die Ukraine deutlich mehr
Raketenabwehrsysteme die irsd helfen um
um Städte zu schützen und deshalb ist es
notwendig da gibt es auch Gespräche der
Bundesregierung drüber mit
Partnerstaaten die von Deutschland ihre
t bekommen haben ob sie sie nicht
einfach jetzt zumindest zeitweise
rüberreichen an die Ukraine ist bis
jetzt kein Zufall dass die
gepard-munition in Deutschland jetzt
wieder gebaut wird das war vor drei
Jahren komplett und denkbar das war auch
so Ende also da wird es jetzt mehr geben
und mehr geben müssen weil wir ja sehen
dass jetzt bist du zu diesem Winter
jetzt kriegt zu Ende ist wünschenswert
aber
nichts zwingen so dass man jetzt rein
rennt wir haben verstanden Frau wir
reden gleich über Taurus ist logisch
dass das auch gerade hier in den
politisch hoch diskutiert wird aber noch
mal zur Situation warum ist die Krim so
wichtig wir haben verstanden es gibt
einen vermehrungskrieg es ist also nicht
möglich sich nur auf die Krim zu
konzentrieren weil die Russen eben auch
noch an 1200 Kilometern
Ostfront stehen und das muss natürlich
auch die ukrainischen Kräfte zermürben
wenn man von einem Zermürbungskrieg
spricht und sie wissen aber ganz genau
die Krim ist genau der Platz von dem aus
die Angriffe auf die Ukraine abgefeuert
werden das heißt also ich habe da die
Startrampe und wenn ich die Startrampe
ungeschoren lasse aber mich an diese an
dieser langen Front die ja nun wirklich
auch eine Aufgabe für sich ist abarbeite
dann habe ich am Ende trotzdem nicht das
eigentliche den Herd gefunden oder oder
ausgeschaltet und das ist eine wirkliche
Herkulesaufgabe ich möchte noch mal was
zu dieser
Zeitspanne von 30 bis 45 Tagen sagen
Milli Nancy also der generalstoffe der
US-Armee und das klingt ja ein bisschen
so ja dann ist aus nach 45 Tagen
so kampfwetter aber nun gibt es
wahrscheinlich so wie es nicht Hitzefrei
gibt für Soldaten auch nicht schlammfrei
für Soldaten das gibt es gar nicht denn
die machen einfach weiter und dass sie
weiter kämpfen das haben sie auch im
vorigen Winter schon gezeigt natürlich
was bleibt ihnen denn anderes übrig und
ich glaube auch bei aller also wir sind
ja jetzt wirklich also der Vergleich mag
nicht ganz stimmen aber eigentlich
erinnert das ein bisschen an
Fußballspiel mit den 80 Millionen
Fußballtrainern die sich an einen Bundes
an Länderspiel der deutschen Mannschaft
anschauen da ist es jetzt auch so alle
gucken von außen zu jeder hat noch
irgendeinen Ratschlag aber am Ende
entscheiden doch die Ukraine wie mit
welcher Taktik mit welchem Einsatz mit
wie vielen Menschen an der Front sie
kämpfen und nur die Ukraine und die
Ukraine werden auch irgendwann für sich
entscheiden müssen
wann ist der Bestand der Nation
gefährdet das heißt also wie viel wie
vor an der Front können wir uns
eigentlich leisten
ist dann überhaupt noch jemand da der
zum Beispiel den Donbass wieder aufbaut
das was wir in dieser Woche gehört haben
und erlebt haben das ist Kim Jong
uninwladiwostok redet mit Putin nicht
nur über Waffen auch das ist die
schreckliche Nachricht das ist also auch
aus dieser Seite verlängert wird aber
das was eine BBC Recherche ergeben hat
ist dass dort ganz konkret geredet wird
über arbeitsklaven aus Nordkorea die den
Donbass aufbauen sollen das heißt also
da ist schon richtig eine ein Plan B
sondern da ist Vollzug schon wird schon
vorbereitet das ist also wirklich
beängstigend all das ist natürlich
verboten fällt unter Sanktion aber es
kümmert den russischen Präsidenten ja
nicht und in also vor im Angesicht diese
Übermacht den Ukrainern dann auch noch
schlauer Ratschläge zu geben finde ich
vermissen das ist gut dass sie es auf
jeden Fall noch sagen wir sind bei
Norbert Röt aufgrund der Frage wenn die
Krim diese Bedeutung hat und wenn von da
und auch ab da alles zu denken ist um
den Ukrainern zum Sieg zu verhelfen
wird es den Ukrainern gelingen
generalfreuding sagt die Ukraine in im
Status von
1991 sei unsere Vision und das was
geschafft werden soll oder sagen Sie es
wird im Grunde nur gelingen diesen
landversorgungsweg abzuschneiden um dann
für die Krim anschließend eine
politische Lösungen zu finden das ist ja
interessanterweise der Gedanke von
silensky ja der ist sogar also ich
glaube dass die Ukraine hat eine
Strategie und die Strategie ist die auch
schon geschildert worden ist den
militärischen Druck zu fokussieren auf
die Krim nicht notwendigerweise und gar
nicht die militärische Eroberung der
Krim aber sie abzuschneiden also
militärischen Druck auf die Krim
auszuüben um dadurch nicht sozusagen den
Sieg zu erringen sondern zu politischen
innenpolitischen Veränderungen in
Russland um sie dadurch herbeizuführen
Stichwort pregorien weil das eine eine
psychologische Wirkung für Russland im
Innern hat das ist nicht dorniert oder
du Hans der Osten sondern das ist die
Krim das ist sozusagen das nationale
Symbol auch der Rückeroberung und wenn
dort das verloren geht verloren zu
drehen rot dann verspricht man sich Rück
politische Rückwirkungen de
Mobilisierung in Russland und von Putin
um auf dadurch wiederum zu einer
politischen Lösung zu kommen das ist
Putin überhaupt verhandeln muss und an
einen ich glaube das mit meiner ein ich
glaube auch dass die Ukraine
verhandeln wird wir werden keine
Verhandlungen mit Putin sehen weil er es
nicht will und die Kalkulation ist dass
das ein geschehen ist dass sie
militärisch so erfolgreich sein müssen
das ist Putin so destabilisiert das ist
doch zu Veränderung kommt und dann der
politische Weg eröffnet wird das ist ich
glaube auch das einzige der einzige Weg
wie man zu einer Lösung kommen kann was
wenn diese Offensive sind noch 83 km
wenn ich richtig gerechnet habe um genau
diesen Landweg der jetzt russisch
besetzt ist im Süden über militopol zu
überwinden wenn das nicht gelingt wird
was dann ist es die dann ist es die
Verlängerung dieses Krieges wenn ich
einen Punkt noch vorher sagen darf wenn
das so klar ist und ich glaube dass man
sagen kann dass es so klar ist dann
finde ich es so ungeheuerlich dass wir
den Ukrainern in diesem Weg nicht alles
das alles geben was wir haben 6000 von
diesen Langstrecken
Mittelstreckenraketen hat der Tierwesen
gesagt schlummern da in den USA von den
Taurus Rakete nicht Rakete
weltweit war ja die Erklärung von
elmarine 600 so und wie wenn das der der
Weg ist und ich kenne noch kenne keinen
der irgendwie eine andere Option
aufzeigt dass wir dann nicht alles geben
und dass wir nicht Anfang des Jahres es
ist nämlich nichts überraschend von dem
was passiert weil es klar war die
Munition wird verbraucht und sie wird
nicht produziert weil es klar war sie
haben zu wenig Waffen alles was passiert
ist die Folge mangelnder Unterstützung
so das wollte ich noch mal vorgelagert
sagen darum ist es und ein unglaubliches
Versagen des Westen an dieser Stelle der
USA aber auch von Deutschland aber jetzt
sagen sie wenn das nicht passiert dann
sage ich ihm was passiert da Krieg wird
weitergehen er wird lange dauern die
Ukraine sagt von sich wir haben ein
Mobilisierungspotenzial von 3 Millionen
Menschen sie haben viel weniger
Bevölkerung aber 3 Millionen das ist
sozusagen
erstmal mobilisieren es ist bitter es
ist traurig aber ich nach meiner
Einschätzung mit aus allen Gesprächen
die ich mit Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
ist der der Wille
die das Überleben der Nation das Landes
mit allem was man hat mit allem
individuellen Leben zu verteidigen
ungebrochen und das wird weitergehen das
ist bitter aber das ist meine
subjektiv sichere Einschätzung die
Ukraine wird nicht kapitulieren sie
werden weitergehen wir fragen noch mal
nach Kiel Frau malla wenn volume
silenski sagt dass bis an die
Verwaltungsgrenzen der Krim heran danach
über eine politische Demilitarisierung
der Krim geredet werden kann und das
dann mit Russland darüber verhandelt
werden muss die Krim politisch zu
demilitarisieren das verstehen wir
richtig wenn sie da anbietet die Krim im
Grunde als ein verhandlungsfaust fand zu
nehmen
des Präsidenten wird dir selbst
kommentieren unser Ziel ist alle unsere
Gebiete zu befreien und zurück zu
erobern hier ist es wichtig nicht die
nicht nur die Position der Ukraine zu
erläutern das ist nicht nur der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine das ist ja
Krieg von zwei Zivilisationen von den
russischen Barbaren und der westlichen
Zivilisation und nun steht die Frage an
die ganze westliche Welt inwieweit sind
Sie bereit in dieser Welt zu leben in
der das Land das mehrere geben mir
Waffen hat auf dein Gebiet auf dein
Boden kommt und sie sich aneignet und
dann sind die Diskussion an ob es
richtig wäre diese Tiere du den wieder
zurückzugeben oder nicht zurückzugeben
wenn man sich diese Frage stellt dann
wird man frei in den Entscheidungen in
den Entscheidungen die in die Rahmen
geschoben sind die von der europäischen
weltgesetzt sind die Regeln und die
Gesetze die sollen uns vor den Kriegen
schützen aber die funktionieren nicht
kollektive Sicherheit die funktioniert
nicht
alle Instrumente die dafür erschaffen
worden um die Kriege zu verhindern die
funktionieren nicht deswegen muss nicht
nur die Ukraine die Frage beantworten
sondern alle was ist wenn ob die Krim
zurückkommt oder nicht zurückkommt alle
westlichen Länder müssen sich die Frage
stellen ob Sie bereit sind in einer Welt
zu leben wo ein Land andere Länder
vernichtet Menschen tötet
Kindergärten aber Krankenhäuser alles in
Aschenputtel liegt wie fühlt man
Verhandlungen mit dem Lande das keine
Regeln wahrnimmt und sich an die Regeln
der zivilisierten Welt nicht halten
möchten sie haben Appell verstanden und
ich stelle Ihnen dennoch die Frage was
Frau Maler wenn diese Offensive nicht
gelingt sie haben markiert in ihrem
letzten Interview 250 Quadratmeter
Quadratkilometer sind schon wieder
rückerobert durch die Ukraine in dieser
Gegenoffensive noch 100.000
Quadratkilometer sind von den Russen
besetzt es gibt diese Hoffnung die
Versorgung der Krim überland
abzuschneiden was wenn das der Ukraine
nicht gelingt der besten liefert Waffen
und er hilft politisch aber gekämpft und
gestorben wird durch die ukrainischen
Soldaten was wenn das nicht gelingt
Süden und noch 50 km Richtung bachmut
also das heißt ein bisschen mehr in der
Zeit der gegen Offensive haben wir
befreien können unser Ziel ist es alle
unsere Gebiete zurück zu erobern
deswegen gibt es für uns keine Rangliste
welche tieretorien wichtiger oder
weniger mehr oder weniger wichtiger sind
wir möchten jeden Quadratkilometer
wieder zurückgegangen die Situation an
der Front dynamisch unser Ziel ist alle
unsere Gebiete zurück zu erobern und das
ist unser Ziel und dazu brauchen Sie
unsere Hilfe wir sind MRT wir sind
wieder in Washington und fragen uns wie
in Washington der Satz von selenski
interpretiert wird den er übrigens nicht
zum ersten Mal sagt dass der Dialog das
ohne Unterstützung machen können
das ist völlig klar und genau darüber
reden wir welche Unterstützung es aus
dem Westen geben wird die Interpretation
des Gedankens von silensky über die
krimen nicht die Krim nicht militärisch
erobern zu müssen sondern eine
Demilitarisierung zu erreichen ist das
vorstellbar als ein Abzug der
Schwarzmeerflotte Putins schwarz mehr
Flotte aussieht was du Pool wie stellt
man sich das in Washington vor
ja es gibt öffentlich keine konkreten
Pläne dazu aber hinter den Kulissen
natürlich schon also wir nehmen wahr
dass man unterstützt welche verhandlungs
Bemühungen ist auch immer gibt zuletzt
ja ein Saudi Arabien wir nehmen auch war
das nächste Woche am Rande der
Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen
silenski Scholz beiden und andere werden
da sein sicherlich auch Gespräche über
diese Frage geführt werden und vor dem
Hintergrund ist für die Amerikaner
eigentlich klar dass es am Ende zu einer
wahrscheinlichen Lösung kommen muss wo
es um die Krim geht im Grunde genommen
das als Faust fahren zu nutzen um Putin
oder eine Nachfolger zum Einlenken zu
bringen dass man aber auf jeden Fall die
gesamten Ostgebiete der Ukraine
zurückerobern will und hier will ich
einmal noch mal klar sagen wenn Herr
Milli in einem Interview von 30 bis 45
Tagen spricht
gleichzeitig aber im selben Interview er
auch sagt er rechnet fest damit dass das
ein Krieg ist der noch Jahre dauern
dann tendieren wir alle dazu diese 30
bis 45 Tage zu nehmen und zu glauben
damit hat er im Grunde genommen ein
klares Ziel formuliert bis dahin muss es
geschafft sein und wenn das nicht
passiert dann ist diese Offensive
gescheitert ich glaube nicht dass Milli
das so gemeint hat wir hatten vor ein
paar Wochen die Gelegenheit eben bei
einer Veranstaltung dabei zu sein wo er
ähnliches gesagt hat und er hat sehr
klar gemacht es geht darum dass wir alle
verstehen es geht nicht so einfach wie
man das sich wünscht erstens und
zweitens man muss die entsprechenden
Waffensysteme natürlich liefern damit
das überhaupt möglich wird und zwar
möglich am Ende eine Lösung zu erreichen
die die Ostgebiete der Ukraine
zurückbringt aber nicht notwendigerweise
auch die Krim sowas hören wir jedenfalls
aus dem staty-partment und auch aus dem
Pentagon das ist interessant er hatte
eben diesen Satz noch gesagt dass es
noch viele Schlachten gibt die nicht
geschlagen sind und die noch Teile und
Gebiete die noch erkämpft werden müssen
wir sind Herr grressel bei der wichtigen
Frage was davon durch die Ukraine in
welchen Fristen zu schaffen ist und wie
wichtig wir sind jetzt bei den Tauros
dafür die berühmten
weiterreichenden
Mittelstrecken oder Kurzstreckenraketen
sind die Ukraine hat selbst gesagt sie
hätte Raketen die auch schon 700
Kilometer weitreichen da wäre die erste
logische Frage warum brauchen Sie die
Taurus noch was von diesen Raketen ja
nicht sehr viel gibt also mit mit
ukrainischen Raketen
ausflugkörpern aus dem Eigenbau wurde
zum Beispiel die Mosbacher singt aber es
gibt natürlich nicht viele nicht tun
[Musik]
mit
ich kann mich jetzt an den Monat nicht
erinnern aber der erste der erste große
Angriff auf die Luftwaffen
wo die Munitionsbunker in die Luft
geflogen
vor dem Bild der Badenden Gäste auf der
Krim das war eine ballistische Rakete
die der Ukraine selber produziert wird
aber die gibt es natürlich nur in
Kleinserien
die ukrainische Rüstungsindustrie stand
vor allen Dingen im März April und der
intensivsten Beschuss durch russische
Marschflugkörper und ballistische
Raketen da ist ist keine große
Produktionskapazität da wenn wir reden
dass wir 500 Taurus haben und das ist
schon schwierig 600 oder 600 an wie viel
wie viel wie viele tun hat die Ukraine
also dass das muss man auch im
Verhältnis sehen mein
dasselbe ich natürlich auch für Skype
und für für Storm kein europäischer
Straße und französische französische
Raketen hat es besonders viel nur
gemeinsam kann man so eine kann man der
Ukraine helfen diese Kampagne gegen den
rückwärtigen Raum der Russen
durchzuhalten weil auch die Franzosen
ist haben keine Wunder Armee wo die
Muskelkörper auf Bäume wachsen wir sind
ja nuripur sie haben es geahnt genau bei
der Frage Anton Hofreiter formuliert
klar und präzise der Kanzler blockiert
und er sollte endlich liefern was hält
die Bundesregierung was hält die
ampelregierung immer noch ab Taurus zur
Verfügung dass wir letztes Jahr
innerhalb der Koalition sehr
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen hat von
der Geschwindigkeit der Entscheidung
sind da gute Stück vorangekommen und es
gibt noch ein paar
Notwendigkeiten der Gespräche mit dem
Partnern und das eine oder andere Datei
zu klären ich gehe davon aus sehr sehr
bald entschieden wird und dass diese
Raketen gehen weil sie gebraucht werden
und das Argument dass man der Ukraine
keine Waffen geben solle die über die
Grenze hinausreichen die ist ja gerade
beschrieben worden ist ja man hat sie
jetzt ja was obwohl gesehen dieser Tage
dass die Ukraine ausreichen solche
Waffen hat und man kann auch mit mit
kleinen Waffen tatsächlich wenn man
direkt an der Grenze steht und das tun
sie ja zu weit oder
Unterschied also das Argument ist keins
aber wir haben die große Notwendigkeit
dass wir
am Ende Dinge versprechen die wir auch
liefern und liefern können gerade
Deutschland hat den letzten Jahren ja
nicht zwingend in Osteuropa in Polen
beispielsweise aber auch in der Ukraine
mit dem ein oder anderen Energieprojekt
großes Vertrauen erweckt und
dementsprechend ist es notwendig dass
man tatsächlich sehr sehr konkret ist da
sind die Gründe man versteht es auch
übrigens nicht wenn man der
Außenministerin davon aus dass wir dass
wir selber machen die Briten und auch
die Franzosen gestellt unsere Systeme
sind technisch noch mal anders dass man
Dinge da nicht zu versempliziert dass
man Dinge über einen Kamm schert die
nicht über einen kamen geschoren werden
können das Taurus System ist eben noch
mal ein anderes System als die anderen
Systeme
also man irgendwie versteht man
technische Komplikationen und technische
Details vielleicht ist der Hintergedanke
noch mal etwas deutlicher auszusprechen
Pistorius und Olaf Scholz Bundeskanzler
unverteidigungsminister sollen
nachgefragt haben ob man die Reichweite
der Taurus minimieren kann ein
sogenanntes geoblocking also ob aus 500
km Reichweite 300 oder 400 gemacht
werden ist das richtig Fragezeichen
stimmt das nicht dass ich wüsste und ich
wüsste auch nicht dass es das
Entscheidende ist entscheidend ist es am
Ende technisch alles stimmt was was äh
du klären ist und und dass die Ukraine
das auch tatsächlich operativ schnell
auch einsetzen können und
dementsprechend gehe ich davon aus dass
die die Fragen die zu beantworten sind
schnell gelöst sind und das sehr schnell
auch tatsächlich die Verkündigung kommen
wird dass dass die Tarot rübergehen weil
die gebraucht wird und blinken sind
verkündet auch schon dass die attackens
jetzt schnell kommen sollen das wird
auch schon eine gewisse Zeit erzählt
wenn ich das mal ganz vorsichtig sage
dass die jetzt gleich und bald kommen
sollen wie verlässlich ist diese letzte
Information dass es sich nur noch um
Tage und Wochen halten soll
auch das wurde uns vor sechs Monaten
schon aus Kreisen der Regierung hier
gesagt dass sie jetzt ganz schnell
kommen werden und ich glaube das
reflektiert eben diesen Streit der
hinter den Kulissen existiert auf der
einen Seite die Militärs auf der anderen
Seite Anthony blink und die politischen
Köpfe innerhalb der Administration die
dem Präsidenten raten er muss das jetzt
machen und der Präsident wird glaube ich
in den nächsten Tagen vielleicht Wochen
entscheiden dass die attackens geliefert
werden noch mal es gibt 4000 davon in
den USA die meisten werden gebraucht um
die koreanische Halbinsel zu schützen
aber die Amerikaner werden sicherlich in
der Lage sein mindestens mal einige
hundert zu liefern die deutschen Taurus
reichen weiter als die attackens und ich
glaube das ist deshalb auch darauf
ankommt dass man miteinander das
abspricht ist gemeinsam macht vielleicht
nicht so wie bei den Panzern wo der eine
das Gefühl erweckter als könnte er die
anderen treiben und nächste Woche wäre
die Gelegenheit für Präsident beiden und
Kanzler Scholz miteinander darüber zu
reden also vielleicht nächste Woche
super Sabine Adler zu dieser Frage vier
Mal war Frau baerbock jetzt schon in
Kiew also wahrscheinlich würde sich auch
Kiew wünschen das nicht zum fünften Mal
Annalena baerbock kommt sondern zum
ersten Mal eine Taurus Rakete für wie
realistisch halten Sie dass die
ampelregierung sich darauf versteht
vielleicht gibt es das Datum dieses
Treffen silensky beiden Scholz am Rande
der
UN-Generalversammlung das wäre ja eine
wirklich positive Nachricht für die
Ukraine das was die Koalition im Moment
und in Person der Kanzler da gerade
macht ist
uns eine Entscheidung als eine überlegte
Entscheidung zu verkaufen deren
Begründung aber nicht geliefert wird
diese Eierei die wir gerade von der
Außenministerin gehört haben macht uns
alle überhaupt nicht schlauer was ist
denn worum geht es denn geht zum
technische Details geht es um
Verfügbarkeit geht es um
Kompatibilität mit den anderen Waffen
wozu eigentlich weshalb ist die
überhaupt nötig also das ist ja wirklich
eine rumeier reife sind die
Öffentlichkeit erfährt gar nichts und
die Öffentlichkeit meiner Meinung nach
ist es ein wieder ein parteitaktisches
Spiel und zwar nach innen in die SPD
selbst hinein nämlich all diese
Menschen die nicht einverstanden sind
mit den Waffenlieferungen ein bisschen
zu besänftigen und zu sagen ja wir
überlegen uns das aber dagegen spricht
doch eine ganz entscheidende Zahl
deutschland ist nach den USA der zweite
der nächste also insgesamt der
zweitgrößte Waffenlieferant das heißt
also auch diese Friedens bewegten sind
ja damit nicht zu überzeugen mit dieser
Zögerlichkeit also dieses politische
Kalkül geht in die eine Richtung nicht
aufgeht in die andere Richtung nicht auf
und es kostet Deutschland ein wirklich
eine Menge Vertrauen Vertrauen das ist
vorhin ich glaube sie haben Sie gesagt
haben dieses Vertrauen ist schon mal
verspielt worden im Zusammenhang mit mit
der Nord Stream eins und zwei und das
machen wir jetzt auf eine anderen Ebene
aber wir verstehen wieder Vertrauen und
am Ende ist diese Leistung die
Deutschland doch erbringt eben wirklich
eine umfänglich Waffenhilfe zu liefern
wird dadurch selbst klein gemacht und
wird dadurch eigentlich negiert und das
ist eigentlich nicht zu verstehen was
steckt dahinter findet Norbert Röttgen
glauben Sie dass es die Sorge ist
russisches Territorium zu erreichen oder
denken Sie auch diese Gedanke ist ihr
mal ausgesprochen platziert worden dass
man dass man sowohl in Washington als
auch in Berlin sagt
die Zeit ohne Putin nach einem Sieg der
Ukraine könnte die viel größere
Unsicherheit bedeuten also kann es sein
dass Regierungen in Europa Angst davor
haben dass ein Russland ohne Putin da
gefährlicher weil zerfallen und damit
atomare Waffen frei sind also was sind
die Gründe zunächst mal will ich mal
aussprechen was jeder weiß es geht nicht
um Technik oder irgendetwas sondern es
geht um den Kanzler der nicht will das
ist nein es geht nicht um Technik weil
die Frage ja über ein halbes Jahr alt
ist jede technische Frage er ist gelöst
könnte gelöst werden jeder weiß ist der
Kanz will nicht sie wollen sie sagen es
aber nicht die Außenministerin will sie
sagt es aber nicht sie eiert rum weil
der Kanzler nicht will das ist die
Wahrheit die einzige Wahrheit die es
gibt er will nicht er wird aber liefern
so wie bei den Leos wenn die Amerikaner
geliefert haben wird er aber so das ist
so so aber es kostet vertrauen aber es
kostet auch Menschen leben das muss man
ganz klar aussprechen und die Begründung
dieser Kanzler liefert ist das Argument
von dem sie sagen es sei kein Argument
er sagt nämlich es muss die
reichweitenverkürzung hergestellt werden
ist schon logisch Unsinn weil die immer
noch groß genug sein wird um nach
Russland zu kommen aber was er damit vor
allen Dingen sagt Misstrauen er sagt ich
traue diesen Ukraine nicht
das ist eine misstrauenserklärung
gegenüber den Ukraine die ja versichern
es gibt die wollen nur angreifen
Stellungen auf ihrem eigenen Territorium
von dem was sie beschossen werden und
ich muss das hier wirklich mal sagen es
ist eine Unverschämtheit es ist eine
Unverschämtheit dem sich verteidigenden
Volk das und Soldaten und Zivilisten
opfert zu Misstrauen zu erklären bei den
bemühen das eigene Land zu verteidigen
warum macht er es das ist die Frage
entschuldigung ich muss noch mal darauf
hinweisen
macht es nicht aber in Deutschland ist
er der der es verhindert und die anderen
von der FDP die hat die sowieso
irgendwie außenpolitisch abgemeldet und
die grünen Eiern mit so das ist die
innenpolitische Lage bei uns so weit
macht es auch dann soweit ein Wahlkampf
für sich denn er hat große Angst davor
dass Trump die Situation ausnutzt um
eine isolationistische Stimmung in den
USA herbeizuführen für ihn ist das immer
noch mal die Frage Trump und der
Wahlkampf gegen Trump trotzdem
entscheidet er auch er sich falsch was
ist der Agenda von Olaf Scholz ich
glaube er hat eine er kommuniziert das
ja nicht weil ich auch schon für
unmöglich halt dass man eine solche
elementare Frage nicht öffentlich
kommuniziert als Kanzler ich glaube bei
deine innenpolitische Agenda und eine
außenpolitische Agenda
und die innenpolitische Agenda ist er
will auch er denkt an den
Wahlkampftermin und er will dich
präsentieren als der Kanzler der die
deutschen davon alle ferngehalten hat
ich war vorsichtig ich war zurückhaltend
wir sind verschont geblieben das ist
glaube ich seine innenpolitische
Botschaft an der erarbeitet auf Kosten
dessen was ich eben beschrieben habe und
außenpolitisch glaube ich geht es dem
Kanzler weit mehr um das zukünftige
Verhältnis zu Russland immer noch und
auch wesentlichen Teilen der SPD als
dass sie die Länder zwischen Deutschland
und Russland interessieren ist leider
eine sehr ungute Kontinuität im
sozialdemokratischen
sozialdemokratischen Russland aus Europa
Politik und das sind die Agenten die ihr
betreiben
gar nicht so unterschiedlich ich wollte
fragen stellen bevor ich bevor ich mich
Wunde ist das nicht nur die Franzosen
und die Briten diese Waffen liefern
sondern auch Deutschland Taurus was
spricht aus ihrer Sicht dagegen
erstens
ich glaube dass wir liefern sollten wir
finden das es gibt technische Dinge die
zu klären sind auch wenn
ingenieurswissenschaftler hier das
anders sehen
wann werden die denn geklärt wir können
doch morgen glaube ich was alles das ist
ein bisschen so das gibt Leute die sagen
manche reden das ist jetzt nicht die
Sache die Sache ist es wird bald
entschieden werden müssen es gibt
technische Details zu klären und wenn
nicht die Tonlage jetzt mitgehen würde
dann würde ich sagen wenn technische
Daten nicht geklärt sind und wir dennoch
liefern und die Dinge nicht
funktionieren dann kostet Menschenleben
ich würde dafür ich würde sehr dafür
plädieren dass wir nicht diese diese
Tonlage miteinander einschlagen weil das
nichts bringt ich habe keine Eierei
gehört ich habe gehört dass die
Außenministerin davon gesprochen hat
dass man ein paar Sachen klären muss und
wir sind dabei die zu klären und ich
hoffe sehr dass es schnell geht weil es
halt intensiv ist das ist ja keine Frage
gleichzeitig hat Frau Adler ja völlig so
Recht darauf hingewiesen das ist
notwendig ist auch nicht diese 30 Tage
zu nehmen und sagen danach ist Schluss
sondern es wird danach weitergehen er
wollte ihn hat
hat ja völlig Recht wenn er sagt je
weniger die Ukraine sich wehren kann
desto länger wird dieser Krieg dauern
dementsprechend müssen wir natürlich
alles dafür tun damit damit die Ukraine
sich selbst verstehen und Frage also
auch noch mal nach Washington und zu MRT
Wissen
stimmt es denn dass die USA tatsächlich
genauso viel Angst da wenigstens genauso
viel Angst davor hat das Putin verliert
und dass das eine brachiale Niederlage
wäre weil es dann einen chaotischen
Zustand in Russland geben könnte ist da
was dran
ich glaube nicht also ich glaube das in
Washington mittlerweile die Einsicht da
ist das Putin nicht derjenige ist der
am Ende tatsächlich eine
Verhandlungslösung anstreben wird und
zweitens wenn er dann dafür ersetzt
werden muss damit man es nur
Verhandlungslösung kommt ist das aus
washingtona Sicht ich sag mal das
kleinere Übel als ein Putin der
möglicherweise zu einem Punkt kommt wo
er zu anderen Waffensystemen greift oder
ähnliches hier hat man das Kalkül
gemacht man muss so schnell wie möglich
so viel wie möglich die Krim zum
Hauptgegenstand machen politisch gesehen
jedenfalls und deswegen noch mal ich
glaube dass Joe Biden auch im Hinterkopf
hat natürlich das nächstes Jahr im
November die Präsidentschaftswahl droht
und das bis dahin die Frage der Ukraine
eine lebensfähigung keine mit möglichst
viel ihres alten Territoriums halt
geklärt sein muss
es ist ein altes Argument von
menschenrechtsverbrechern und Diktatoren
zu sagen ich bin unantastbar weil sonst
gibt keine Stabilität Assad hat eine
halbe Million Menschen seine eigene
Bevölkerung umgebracht genau mit diesem
Argument Putin bringt nicht einmal diese
Stabilität das hat man nicht nur
Überprüfungen gesehen warum war aber
nicht bei G20 nicht nur weil er Angst
hatte verhaftet zu werden sondern es
gibt viele Leute die sagen man weiß gar
nicht ob wie die innere verfasst hat ist
oder einfach so aus dem Land gehen kann
er wollte Russland wieder zu groß macht
machen jetzt bleibt ihm nur noch eine
Partnerschaft eine Waffen Bruderschaft
mit mit mit Nordkorea das ist das
isolierteste Land der Welt das liegt
eben offensichtlich an uns wie schnell
die Ukraine aus dieser brutalen
Situation kommt und insofern fragen
wir diskutieren jetzt natürlich die neu
zu liefernden Waffensysteme wir sollten
aber bei allen Diskussionen auch nicht
vergessen die Waffensysteme die wir
schon geliefert haben auch zu nähren
durch Munition durch Ersatzteile durch
weiteres Gerät also Leopard fallen ja
auch im Gefecht aus und es wird noch
leider länger dauern und da ist auch ein
Problem dass wir
rüstungspolitisch wenn man sagt okay
neue Leopard wir haben jetzt die Bauzeit
von drei Jahren ein bisschen runter
gedrückt weil es mehr Bestellungen gibt
aber der das Signal an Putin er glaubt
einen langen Krieg gewinnen zu können
indem man den Westen einfach ausbluten
indem man den Krieg so lange führt bis
irgendwann amerikanischer Präsidentin
Hut drauf hat und ob das jetzt zwei
Jahre oder drei oder fünf Jahre ist er
richte den Krieg sich so ein dass er
unter Anführungszeichen bequem
weiterführen kann wenn bei uns nur das
Signal kommt die Ukraine kriegt was
gerade in der Garage finden was wir
selber nicht mehr brauchen das geben wir
ab wenn da nicht das Signal kommt jetzt
nehmen wir das erst wir fahren hoch
nicht mehr im Bereich der Munition auch
der Kampffahrzeuge der pioniermittel der
Flugzeuge und wir machen Dinge Fragen ja
wir machen die Dinge frei die die
Ukraine braucht wir kaufen das nach und
wir versorgen die Ukraine durch einen
Krieg durch und wir sagen nicht nur es
langer Zeit sondern wir machen das auch
so glaubhaft dass man im Moskau es sieht
dass die das Durchhalten dann
verschieben sich nämlich auch in Moskau
die Wahrnehmungen nur das sind wir
leider noch nicht und das geht leider
nicht nur in Deutschland auch in vielen
anderen europäischen Staaten dann leider
immer im Kleinen unter und dann gibt's
die üblichen Fingerzeige aber du nicht
aber ihr nicht aber macht nicht aber das
Problem ist das Endresultat der
Rüstungsproduktion ist aus Moskau sich
nicht beeindrucken und solange das nicht
beeindruckend ist Vater in diesem Kurs
vor Ort und wir sind Frau noch mit
diesem letzten Gedanken und dieser
letzten Frage bei Ihnen wie groß ist
ihre Hoffnung dass dieses Misstrauen
dass der Druck dass die Situation für
die Ukraine jetzt wieder und wieder
nachzuweisen dass sie kämpfen dass der
irgendwann mal aus den Leitungen
verschwindet
bemüht sich mit allen Kräften um die
Ukraine zu vernichten das Endziel ist
die Besatzung des ganzen Landes man muss
keine Illusionen darüber haben und
selbstverständlich arbeiten sie daran
uns mitten Waffen zu vernichten und auch
auf dem Informationswege ihr Schlüssel
Aufgabe wenn es hier über die westlichen
Linden sprechen uns zu diskreditieren
als waffenempfänger es gibt ja ganz
viele Diskussionen zum Thema
Krieg über den Krieg kann man
diskutieren nein kann man nicht das ist
ein
internationales Verbrechen da gibt es
keine Diskussion darüber
die Ukraine hat mich genug Waffen um
sich voran zu um voranzukommen um zu
siegen das ist offen das weiß die ganze
Welt und selbstverständlich rechnen wir
mit Hilfe und Unterstützung die Ukrainer
haben
unsere Kraft unsere Professionalität der
Soldaten nach vielen NATO Standards
haben wir in dieser Zeit als wir noch
NATO beitreten wollten noch vor dem
großflächigen Eingriff ein sehr hohes
Niveau unserer Streitkräfte erreicht und
unsere Soldaten und Offiziere haben sehr
hohes Niveau und weiter als Faktor ganz
wichtig die Waffen die Waffen
Langstreckenwaffen das sind die
Luftwaffen das ist die Munition und
Luftverteidigung das sind nun die
Schlüsselfaktoren ohne sitzen wir nicht
siegen für
eine gegen Offensive wir haben Russland
nicht anfassen damit ihn Stabilität
herrscht soll man nicht sagen ist das
jetzt stabil mehr Instabilität kann man
sich in der Welt nicht vorstellen seit
Jahrzehnten versucht man gegen die
Kriege vorzugehen und der schlimmste
Krieg ist nun vor unseren Augen
wir sind dankbar sie in diese Sendung
dazu gehört zu haben Frau Müller danke
nach Kiew danke für die Diskussion hier
heute in der Runde danke nach Washington
zu MRT wissen und wir geben mit
fliegenden Fahnen zu Markus Lanz der
heute unter anderem Luisa Neubauer zu
Gast hat und andere interessante Gäste
wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag wieder
wenn Sie mögen gleiche Stelle gleich
kommen Sie gut durch den Abend vielen
Dank noch mal weiter
[Musik]